[Music]
you're here to talk about your your film
salmon fishing yeah in the yemen which
when i first heard about this movie uh a
while ago i thought that sounds like a
documentary no it's not a document i'm
just here mainly to tell you that salmon
fishing in yemen is not a documentary
film about salmon fishing in yemen
however it is a film about salmon
fishing in the yemen and once you've
seen it you'll wonder what else it could
ever have been called
but before you see it you might wonder
why did they call it that you know yeah
it's that kind of title but i we made it
as that and it's it's based on a novel a
very very sweet funny novel and it's a
lovely um it's it's a lovely movie it's
got a nice gentle romance in it it's got
some kind of political satire which i'm
very happy yeah i think politicians are
always good fun to poke fun out they
make it so easy i don't find that myself
i don't know
i like to keep away from i never like to
make fun of anyone uh no
politicians in the future maybe you
should have a crack oh i would never do
that
you're crazy yeah and at the middle of
it is this mad idea of the the film is
about a
rich shake from the yemen who wants to
introduce his passion sport of salmon
fishing to the deserts of his country
and he feels it will bring peace and
prosperity and uh to his people and i'm
a fishery scientist that helps them do
that and then i fall in love with emily
blunt in it which is also easy to do and
uh it's a great fun it's a lovely lovely
show i have to say uh emily blunt is uh
one of my uh favorite actresses is
absolutely gorgeous very talented and uh
every time i see her in something i i
fall in love with her she's funny here
she's a funny funny girl as well she had
us laughing for months and she's a very
good fisher woman also oh she can fish
yeah
she she caught my dog what yeah we were
because the fly fishing you have to t i
don't want to get too boring and
technical but you cast the line behind
you in the air and then you have to push
it forward so we were practicing on this
pawn me and amar who there's a gentleman
that plays the shake and we said come on
emily you should have a goal you should
try it yeah you'll catch a fish there's
loads of fish so she came out and then
her first cast she threw the line behind
her and then as she pushed it forward
there's terrible yelp and i'd i'd forgot
to tie my dog up now before i go on it
wasn't hurt
it was just caught in his fur a little
bit oh okay it wasn't like i pictured a
little dog going into the
and then a shark
whoa yeah i got another dog
[Laughter]
oh he's fine he's fine we have a picture
of your dog uh this is sitting in
oh my goodness is that your is that your
side car yeah i've got a couple of them
i got i i just said after i finished the
film beginners because i i
acted with a little dog in that film and
i realized there was a sort of gap in my
life and then i found adult uh sid who's
a little rescue dog but i and i love to
ride bikes i thought how am i going to
do this i can't ride bikes and knock a
boat with him so i bought a side car
that one is a russian bike called ural
which is good fun
and then i got another one which has got
a nice windscreen on it and a little
convertible roof that is so cool he's
got a really good what i want to do i
want to commute to work with you andy
all right the two of us do that i think
it'd be really fun i i would rather
drive though
really funny
uh well we have a clip here uh from
salmon fishing uh in the yemen anything
we need to know for this clip this is
this is towards the end of the story and
i i'm a i tie flies you know and i found
a little bit of the first time i've ever
ever in her apartment i find this bit of
thread that i've kept in my pocket and i
make it make a fly with that thread
let's take this clip from salmon fishing
in the yemen
is that um willie jones no this is a new
one i've invented that's it
what's it called
this one is called the chetwood talbot
beauty
that's very nice
it's true
you're not being funny no i don't have a
sense of humor as you recall that is
true
[Music]
beautiful yes yes
[Music]
you guys have a really nice chemistry